turning now to Israel the Trump
administration is reversing the Obama
administration's approach towards
Israeli settlements the US public
statements on settlement activities in
the West Bank have been inconsistent
over decades in 1978 the Carter
Administration categorically concluded
that Israel's establishment of civilian
settlements was inconsistent with
international law however in 1981
President Reagan disagree with that
conclusion and stated that he didn't
believe that the settlements were
inherently illegal subsequent
administration's recognized that
unrestrained settlement activity could
be an obstacle to peace but they wisely
imprudently recognized that dwelling on
legal positions did in advance peace
however in December 2016 at the very end
of the previous administration secretary
Kerry changed decades of this careful
bipartisan approach by publicly
reaffirming the suppose a league
illegalities Edelman's after carefully
studying all sides of the legal debate
this administration agrees with
President Reagan the establishment of
Israeli civilian settlements in the West
Bank is not per se inconsistent with
international law I want to emphasize
several important considerations first
look we recognize that as Israeli courts
have the legal conclusions relating to
individual citizen settlements must
depend on an assessment of specific
facts and circumstances on the ground
therefore the Unites States government
is expressing no view on a legal status
of any individual settlement the Israeli
legal system affords an opportunity to
challenge settlement activity and assess
humanitarian considerations connected to
it the Israeli courts have confirmed the
legality of certain settlement
activities and it's concluded that
others cannot be illegally sustained
second we're not addressing or
prejudging the ultimate status of the
West Bank this is for the Israelis and
the Palestinians to negotiate
international law does not compel a
particularly outcome nor create any
legal obstacle to a negotiated
resolution
third the conclusion that we will no
longer recognize Israeli settlements as
per se inconsistent with international
law is based on the unique facts history
and circumstances presented by the
establishing the civilian settlements in
the West Bank our decision today does
not prejudice or decide legal
conclusions regarding situations in any
other parts of the world and finally
finally calling the establishing of
civilian settlements inconsistent with
international law hasn't worked it
hasn't advanced the cause of peace the
hard truth is there will never be a
judicial resolution to the conflict and
arguments about who is right and wrong
as a matter of international law will
not bring peace this is a complex
political problem that can only be
solved by negotiations between the
Israelis and the Palestinians the United
States remains deeply committed to
helping facilitate peace and I will do
everything I can to help this cause the
United States encourages Israelis and
the Palestinians to resolve the status
of Israeli settlements in the West Bank
in any final status negotiations and
further we encourage both sides to find
a solution that promotes protects the
security and welfare of Palestinians and
Israelis alike